de raúl bueno como ustedes lo decían
como lo decía el primer ministro
británico lo más importante quizás esta
cumbre ha sido mostrar la unidad de los
países desarrollados en cuanto al
conflicto ucraniano a condenar la guerra
en rusia sobre todo de rusia perdón
sobre todo después de ese ataque ayer
encontramos centro comercial en el
centro de ucrania se equivocaba en la
primera ministerial 30 millones bueno
son 29 billones de dólares de ayuda a
ucrania pensando también ya en la
reconstrucción obviamente apoyo militar
eeuu hallen ha avanzado un poco de esos
misiles aéreos que va a entregar al
presidente este les pille a su gobierno
para seguir haciendo frente a la guerra
hace poco el presidente manuel macrón da
una conferencia de prensa y decía rusia
no puede ni debe ganar aunque rechazaba
esa declaración que quería el presidente
se les pide decir que rusia es un país
que viola los derechos humanos
concretamente él dice que no adhiere a
esa dilatación en general lo más
importante o más concreto quizás de esta
cumbre es
a ese paquete de dinero de 45 billones
de dólares para hacer frente a la
hambruna que ha generado la guerra en
ucrania pero que también venía siendo
arrastrada por la crisis del coi 19 la
idea es sacar de aquí al año 2030 a 500
millones de personas del riesgo de
hambruna y desnutrición
también los países se mostraron unidos
en la idea de poder sacar ese trigo y
espera no están siendo bloqueados en
territorio ucraniano recordemos que la
onu está realizando al respecto unas
gestiones para poder atacar las se le
pide también a rusia que deje de
bombardear puertos infraestructura
portuaria o de carreteras para poder
seguir sacando ese trigo al mundo
también otra medida importante con
respecto
esta cumbre ha sido lo del clima aunque
no ha habido hay que decirlo ninguna
medida concreta más que las buenas
intenciones de seguir cumpliendo la
cuerda del clima de parís